[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
über richter und christian sievers
guten abend zuletzt meldeten sich die zu
wort die fast schon mitleid hatten mit
armin laschet und mitleid ist das letzte
was ein profi politiker gebrauchen kann
heute abend dann ein auftritt in der
cdu-zentrale nachdem die
nachrichtenagenturen mühe haben ihn in
eine griffige schlagzeile zu fassen
laschet deutet bereitschaft zu verzicht
auf cdu-vorsitz ankam am ende heraus
oder laschet will zur neuaufstellung
parteitag vorschlagen
da sagt also einer unterm strich ich
kann es machen muss aber nicht das war
kein rücktritt aber im knallharten
politgeschäft in dem der unbedingte
machtanspruch alles ist wirkt es wie ein
schon vor diesem abend war vieles offen
in der cdu seit 18.30 gilt das umso mehr
mathis feldhoff
ende erzählen geschichten auch die von
armin laschet es ist die erzählung von
seiner offenheit gegenüber fdp und den
grünen und vom plötzlichen ausschluss
der union armin laschet tritt heute
abend vor die kameras und seinen letzten
trumpf anzubieten er ist bereit seinen
platz zu räumen um jamaika zu retten und
den rest seiner würde ich habe bereits
in den gesprächen deutlich gemacht an
der person wird es nicht scheitern
und das habe ich heute auch der fraktion
berichtet es geht nicht um die person
armin laschet es geht um das projekt für
das land
armin laschet weiß in diesem moment dass
seine zeit als cdu-chef abläuft
gestern hatte markus söder den letzten
block 1 geschlagen
jamaika sei tot sagt er und klingt dabei
wie ein nachruf auf laschet die union
ist auch nicht jetzt nach einer so
klaren vorprägung das ersatzrad ist
jetzt auch die aufgabe als union sich
neben der natürlich offenheit die
wenigen gesprächen geführt haben jetzt
auf dauer auch die realitäten
anzuerkennen die sich aus diesen
entscheidungen ergeben laschets
kandidatur stand von anfang an unter
einem schlechten stern
eigene fehler das lachen in der flut der
machtkampf mit söder eine zerstrittene
fraktion gescheitert ist der rheinländer
an sich und den eigenen leuten das ist
ganz wichtig dass wir in den nächsten
wochen dokumentieren dass es nicht nur
darum geht sich mit schlaf fragen ins
kanzleramt zu fahren markus söder war
erkennbar der kandidat der herzen in der
antreiber wir brauchen einfach mehr
tempo und power laschet wollte den
einfachen weg einfach merkels nachfolger
werden nahtlos anknüpfen kontinuität
verkörpern eine strategie die wohl nie
aufgehen konnte ich bin armin laschet
und darauf können sie sich verlassen
am abend kommen die spitzen der union in
berlin zusammen dass routine treffen vor
dem bundesrat wird zur krisensitzung
laschet bereitschaft zum platz machen
wird bereits wie sein erfolg der
rücktritt wahrgenommen aber das ist ein
wichtiges signal jetzt auch in die
parteibasis er selber weiß dass er
einige missgeschick lichkeiten auch im
wahlkampf persönlich zu verantworten hat
aber die ursache für die verlorene wahl
und sie ist wirklich eine verlorene wahl
liegt nicht alleine bei ihm wir müssen
die neuaufstellung der cdu personell
jetzt beginnen und dafür hat heute ein
wichtiges signal gesetzt ich halte das
für einen erwartbaren prozess der jetzt
eintritt ich habe ihn auch in der
vergangenheit zu verstanden dass er
nicht an personalien etwas scheitern
lässt das habe ich immer so
interpretiert als ob er dann auch einen
weg frei macht armin laschet folgt heute
abend als letzter ein lockerer spruch
noch scheinbar gut gelaunt anspannung
die abfällt aber den jetzt folgenden
übergang noch mitgestalten kann scheint
wie die nacht im dunkeln zu liegen
war so ein bisschen licht in diese
dunkle nacht zu bringen mit theo koll
theo guten abends das ist kein
klassischer rücktritt aber es klingt in
einer sehr machtbewussten partei auch
nicht nach zukunft war das heute ein
echter laschet
das können wir dann so formulieren ja es
klingt nach zukunft aber nicht mehr
unbedingt mit armin laschet das war
heute mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit der
beginn des rückzugs aufwerten und zwar
in doppelter hinsicht einerseits hält an
die lasche die rest option einer
möglichen jamaika regierung ihr
vergrössern als von vielen gedacht und
für so wichtig dass er das nicht an sich
selbst scheitern lassen möchte etwas
anders ist es gelagert beim
parteivorsitz da tobt ja in der union
eine verdeckte feldschlacht mit
zahlreichen möglichen laschet
nachfolgern und diese neuaufstellung
wähler noch moderieren das heißt er will
diesen prozess der veränderung führen
ohne das er wirklich klar gemacht hat ob
er am ende noch teil des ganzen ist in
nordrhein westfalen hat er die
konkurrenz um seine nachfolge jedenfalls
entsprechend
geräuschlos gelöst aber danach war er
dann raus bei der bundestagswahl
dramatisch abgestraft hat armin laschet
ja erleben müssen wie war der alte
spruch sein kann wer genug partei
freunde hat braucht keine feinde mehr
ist dann zu erwarten dass dieser
verdeckte machtkampf demokrat erwähnt
hast in der cdu jetzt öffentlich er wird
also davon ist auszugehen denn jetzt ist
ja relativ klar mögliche bewerber müssen
vor dem gang auf die offene politische
bühne kein königs mord mehr begehen der
alte könig hat angekündigt seine eigene
nachfolge regeln zu helfen also geht es
jetzt darum sich als der bestmögliche
thronfolger zu zeigen und das wird in
einem wie auch immer gearteten
wettbewerb in ob daraus eine offene
feldschlacht wird ist glaube ich noch
nicht ausgemacht in nordrhein westfalen
wurde sie vermieden auch das scheint
diesmal das ziel von armin laschet zu
sein in jedem fall ist der prozess der
neuaufstellung der union jetzt
eingeläutet und dann auch kurz vor was
heißt das jetzt für eine mögliche
jamaika option ist jetzt klarer wer
dafür ansprechpartner bei der union wäre
nein es ist auch wieder eine dieser
typischen scharfen laschet an sagen er
möchte dass die union sich für die
jamaika option bereit hält und zwar bis
zur letzten sekunde einer
regierungsbildung damit einher geht sich
ja auch die überzeugung dass er als
kanzlerkandidat eigentlich der legitime
verhandler einer solchen option wäre der
ansprechpartner bleibe der
parteivorsitzende meint er heute abend
dafür habe er sogar die rückendeckung
der gräben nur
wenn er als hindernis empfunden würde
dann eben ohne ihn aber es ist überhaupt
nicht ersichtlich wäre dann statt seiner
eine solche verhandlung legitimerweise
führen könnte wir reden gleich noch
weiter theorie erst doch diese beiden
hinweise gleich nach uns heute mal
britinnen mit eigenen ambitionen zu gast
friedrich merz und bei zdf heute im netz
ein lesenswerter kommentar zum thema und
dann kommen wir jetzt zur suche nach
einer neuen regierung ein ergebnis hat
die bereits bei der suche nach
wortungetüme die irgendwie die lage
beschreiben und dabei gleichzeitig
inhaltlich möglichst vage bleiben da
sind die beteiligten enorm vorangekommen
die fdp sieht eine art fortschritts
freundliches zentrum die grünen sprechen
von vertrauens raum seit heute ist die
spd mit dabei sie sprechen also zu dritt
und da sind jetzt ampel analogien
gefragt kann sie am ende auf grün
springen nach dem heutigen tag sieht es
weiterhin so aus wie frank buchwald
berichtet
klima aktivisten von greenpeace machen
schon am morgen klar was sie erwarten
und die grünen zeigen sich bester laune
sieben stunden später dann die
generalsekretäre alle loben die
gespräche vertrauen ist das zauberwort
man kann
vertraulich und vertrauensvoll
miteinander reden über alle themen
natürlich das ja auch klar ist da noch
ein ganzes stück des weges zu gehen aber
ich glaube lösung lassen sich finn noch
aber gibt es eben viele rote linien etwa
beim klimaschutz die grünen wollen schon
2030 raus aus der kohle ein tempolimit
und dann nur noch emissionsfreie autos
beim kohleausstieg sind spd und fdp sich
einig spätestens
2038 tempo 130 aber plant auch die spd
dazu 15 millionen elektroautos
tempolimit oder ein haus für verbrenner
das wollen die liberalen nicht
christian lindner kann sie gut
gebrauchen die kleine stärkung auch die
fdp hat ihre roten linien etwa
beisteuern keine steuererhöhungen kein
aufweichen der schuldenbremse zur
schuldenbremse steht auch die spd sie
aber will höhere steuern für
gutverdiener und auf vermögen ebenso die
grünen für investitionen in den
klimaschutz planen sie auch neue
schulden
am abend dabei gibt sich die fdp
zuversichtlich es gibt themen bei denen
wird es nicht einfach und umso wichtiger
war es für uns in einem dreier gespräch
herauszufinden ob es die bereitschaft
gibt auch größere hürden gemeinsam zu
nehmen
das haben wir heute gesehen
olaf scholz bewahrt poker face der mann
der kanzler werden will braucht beide
partner zum regieren scholz muss deshalb
ausbalancieren für seine spd markiert
der mindestlohn die rote linie die
sozialdemokraten wollen ihn auf 12 euro
anheben genau wie die grünen eine lösung
mit der fdp scheint machbar sie würde
das thema gerne der mindestlohn
kommission von arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften über lassen
es geht darum dass man mit einem
politischen stil jetzt in die gespräche
reingeht der nicht von gewinnern und
verlierern geprägt ist sondern der dafür
sorgt dass am ende
alle parteien eine regierung gemeinsam
bilden alle parteien auch ihre
schwerpunkte setzen können immerhin bei
vielen themen gibt es auch
gemeinsamkeiten
digitalisierung und bildung etwa oder in
der gesellschaftspolitik die drei wollen
nächste woche weiter verhandeln das
könnte spannend werden
nach der sondierung und vor echten
koalitionsgesprächen jetzt also wie es
heute hieß erst mal eine vertiefte
sondierung theo das klingt nach es läuft
aber wir wollen das noch nicht so laut
sagen
ja eigentlich haben sie es damit
ziemlich deutlich gesagt wir sind ja in
einer phase von polit prosa da sich alle
vertraulichkeit über die inhalte
verordnet haben erfährt dann die
öffentlichkeit nur er gefühlige vokabeln
wie diese berühmte vertiefte sondierung
wir sagen wir kommen uns näher sagen
euch aber nicht bei was und wie auch das
ist zwar eine der lehren aus 2017 könnte
aber dazu führen dass ich am ende viele
wähler sehr erstaunt die augen reiben
was denn da so an zugeständnissen von
ihrer partei gemacht wurde bei der
verkehrsampel tee oder gibt es rot und
grün gelb ist zwar da wird aber gerne
überfahren das ist bei der polit ampel
anders oder
absolut denn erstens wissen ja alle
beteiligten sei 2017 die fdp ist in der
lage auszusteigen werden sie sich nicht
gut behandelt fühlt da dürfte das geld
also eher so eine art warnleuchte sein
und zweitens sind die schnittmengen
zwischen spd und grünen ja viel größer
das heißt auch da dürfte die
aufmerksamkeit für die liberalen und
ihre forderung notwendigerweise bei den
anderen beiden ausgeprägter sein
knackpunkte und schnittmengen das werden
wir heute gar noch höheren theo für die
heute abend herzlichen dank nach berlin
und dann heute im streit zwischen der
europäischen union und ihre
mitgliedsländer
habe buti vorgeschlagen
teile des eu vertrages seien in polen
verfassungswidrig erklärt das
verfassungsgericht in warschau damit
könnte sich polen über urteile des
europäischen gerichtshofs schlicht
hinwegsetzen da applaudiert die
nationalkonservative regierung in
warschau bei der eu dürften die
bestehenden zweifel enorm wachsen wie
unabhängig die polnische justiz noch ist
aus warschau anne hertz lieb
um himmels willen wohin führst du dieses
land singen die demonstranten vor dem
polnischen verfassungsgericht heute
abend
das urteil verfolgen sie per livestream
die eu-organe überschreiten ihre
kompetenzen und die polnische republik
an nicht demokratisch und souverän
agieren
ein urteil mit wucht
wir haben verloren wir gehen raus aus
der eu
nein wir gehen nicht raus es ist nur ein
urteil
doch die begründung der richter hat es
in sich
der eu vertrag ist der polnischen
verfassung untergeordnet und wie jeder
internationaler vertrag muss er
verfassungskonform sein
motto war für den bielefelder
rechtswissenschaftler franz meier
befindet sich polen damit offen auf
konfrontationskurs mit brüssel das
polnische verfassungsgericht hat heute
entschieden dass der zentrale artikel
der eu-verträge der die rolle des
europäischen gerichtshofs beschreibt mit
der polnischen verfassung unvereinbar
ist dahinter steht letztlich das
argument dass die europäische union
nicht das recht hat die unabhängigkeit
der polnischen justiz zu überprüfen
obwohl diese unabhängigkeit ja
seinerzeit beitritts voraussetzung war
polen stelle damit die
geschäftsgrundlage zwischen dem land und
der eu in frage so experten
für polen und die eu ist das ein großes
problem das gelöst werden muss
vielleicht wird es zu einer klage von
seiten der eu gegen polen kommen aber
ehrlich gesagt wir stehen an der wand
polen wirft sich selbst rechtlich aus
der eu aus
eine entwicklung die außer kontrolle
geraten könnte
ich denke niemand in der polnischen
regierung plant den poleksic aber auch
david cameron hat den wechsel nicht
geplant und wir wissen wie es geendet
ist
unsichere aussichten doch eins ist klar
polen wendet sich zunehmend ab von
europa
ja und wie wird die europäische union
reagieren bonner krüger ist heute den
gesamten tag beim treffen der
justizminister der eu in luxemburg
gewesen gunnar guten abend wie geht es
jetzt weiter
ja die eu muss reagieren und die eu da
sind ja viele institutionen wir stehen
jetzt vor dem europäischen gerichtshof
und hier fand heute abend eine
feierstunde statt da wurden neue richter
in ihr amt eingeführt und eigentlich
soll es eben feierlich sein und dann kam
dieses urteil aus warschau und die
stimmung war entsprechend mau das
berichten uns europa abgeordnete die die
dabei waren und die sagen auch nun müsse
die eu kommission handeln sie müsse
jetzt den polen sie müsse der polnischen
regierung die milliarden aus dem wm aus
dem aus dem wiederaufbau von nun sperren
denn in einem land dass das eu-recht
nicht achte sei eben auch das geld der
eu nicht sicher sie wurden ein bisschen
enttäuscht auf der anderen straßenseite
wo eben der eu justizkommissar mit den
justizministern zusammen saß und sagte
man müsse erst mal prüfen man habe ja
viele werkzeuge aber genau das ist ja
die kritik an der kommission dass sie
sich verhalten wie ein häuslebauer bei
dem es reinregnet der aber mit seinen
werkzeugen nicht zur tat schreitet und
was für ein signal ist heute sogar so
etwas wie ein pole exit also der
austritt polenz aus der europäischen
union näher gerückt
es ist ja so in der eu dass sie ihren
mitgliedern strafen aufbrummen kann dass
sie ihnen gelder sperren kann dass sie
die in sogar stimmrechte entziehen kann
aber dass sie eben niemanden aus diesem
klub rauswerfen kann gehen müsste polen
selber aber die polen die wollen ja gar
nicht gehen laut umfragen und die
regierung in warschau die hatte auch
weiterhin interesse an dem geld aus
brüssel was die regierung mit diesem
urteil eigentlich erreichen wollte ist
eine art blankoscheck sie wollten geld
weiter aus brüssel aber eben ohne
kontrolle und die kommission wäre mehr
als schlecht beraten wenn sie diesen
scheck einlösen würde interessante
einordnung aus luxemburg heute abend
unter krueger herzlichen dank dafür
seit längerem schon schreiben wir uns
alle er die augen wie häufig beim thema
corona in diesem land die datenlage doch
zu wünschen übrig lässt das war so bei
der frage wo exakt grassiert das virus
und warum das war so bei der belegung
der intensivstation und das ist jetzt so
wenn es darum geht wie viele deutsche
sind geimpft mir hat kassel ja
möglicherweise sind in deutschland mehr
menschen geimpft als offiziell gemeldet
das ergab eine schätzung des robert koch
institutes die sich auf umfragen stützt
demnach können bis zu 84 prozent der
erwachsenen einfach und 80 prozent
doppelt geimpft sein das wären fünf
prozent mehr als die statistik erfasst
das gäbe mehr sicherheit für herbst und
winter so gesundheitsminister sparen aus
heutiger sicht werde es keine
zusätzlichen beschränkungen mehr
brauchen von patientenschützern kam
umgehend kritik bei der beurteilung des
im fortschritt sollten nicht umfragen
zählen sondern fakten er viele geimpfte
frage sich ob und wann sie eine
auffrischung brauchen und dazu gibt es
eine neue antwort der ständigen
impfkommission
sie empfiehlt den sogenannten booster
für alle geimpften über 70 ebenso wie
für bewohner und beschäftigte in
altenheimen selbst wenn sie jünger sind
auch für medizinisches personal mit
patientenkontakt sei die dritte spritze
sinnvoll
in syrien befinden sich nach wie vor
deutsche es anhängerinnen in
gefangenenlagern nun wurden weitere von
ihnen zurückgeholt ein charter flugzeug
landete in der nacht in frankfurt am
main an bord acht mütter und ihre 23
kinder gegen sechs der frauen lägen
haftbefehle vor drei wurden bei ihrer
ankunft festgenommen ihnen wird
vorgeworfen nach syrien aus gereist zu
sein um den sogenannten islamischen
staates zu unterstützen
vor dem landgericht neuruppin hat der
prozess gegen einen ehemaligen ss
wachmann begonnen wegen beihilfe zum
mord in
3500 18 fällen der 100 jährige soll
zwischen 1942 und 45 dazu beigetragen
haben dass im konzentrationslager
sachsenhausen tausende insassen getötet
wurden bis zum ende des zweiten
weltkrieges waren dort mehr als 200.000
menschen inhaftiert zehntausende wurden
ermordet oder starben durch die
lebensfeindlichen bedingungen
bundeskanzlerin merkel ist zu einem
abschiedsbesuch nach rom gereist bei
einem gespräch mit franziskus ging es
unter anderem um die aufarbeitung von
missbrauchsfällen in der katholischen
kirche später trafen sie sich am
kolosseum wieder bei einem
interreligiösen friedenstreffen auch
politische stand auf der agenda italiens
ministerpräsident draghi dankte merkel
für die unterstützung in der korona
krise
in deutschland ist vieles in bewegung es
geht um eine neue regierung für mehr
ausführlich in der sendung schon darüber
geredet bei unseren nachbarn in
österreich die umgekehrte frage kann
sich der aktuelle kanzler noch halten
eine neue dimension ist erreicht der
eindruck ist verheerend sagt der
österreichische vizekanzler von den
grünen und er meint damit die
korruptionsvorwürfe gegen bundeskanzler
sebastian kurz gegen ihn und eine reihe
seiner mitarbeiter ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft wegen des verdachts
auf untreue bestechlichkeit und
bestechung bzw der beihilfe dazu
die ermittler stützen sich dabei auf
eine ganze reihe von internen sms
nachrichten die sich in der tat zunächst
mal abenteuerlich lesen österreich das
ja keinen mangel hart ran politskandalen
hält den atem an wolf christian ullrich
aus
wien erlebte in diesen stunden ein
politisches erdbeben hunderte fordern am
abend stehen rücktritt des
bundeskanzlers
ermittlungen gegen den bundeskanzler
wegen anstiftung zur bestechung der
größten politskandale seite ibiza affäre
am morgen braute sich zusammen die
grünen scheinen auf angriff und
palastrevolte überraschen damit das
ganze land die vorwürfe gegen die spitze
der bvb wiegen schwer und deshalb geht's
um stabilität und ordnung und stabilität
und verantwortung um stabilität und
aufklärung worum geht es laut
staatsanwaltschaft soll ein zirkel von
kurz vertrauten vor gut fünf jahren vp
freundliche artikel und umfragen in der
zeitung österreich bestellt haben
bezahlt über das finanzministerium als
mit steuergeld und das alles damit kurz
mit einer maßgeschneiderten kampagne
erst parteivorsitzender und dann kanzler
wird gegen kurz wird deshalb wegen der
anstiftung zur bestechung ermittelt für
die grünen ein skandal zu viel sie
stellen die handlungsfähigkeit des
kanzlers in frage uns ist klar wir
können nicht zur tagesordnung übergehen
die vorwürfe wiegen schwer
es steht korruption im raum
die opposition will einen
misstrauensantrag stellen er kann diese
funktion und dieses amt jetzt nicht mehr
ausführen ohne dass es kosten schaden
nimmt ich habe gesagt dass sie mir raten
dass er kanzler zurücktritt
um 16 uhr endlich statement des
bundeskanzlers manche erwarten den
rücktritt doch es kommt anders
dass wir weiterhin stabile verhältnisse
in unserem land haben wenn die grünen
also nicht mehr diese zusammenarbeit
fortsetzen wollen und sich andere
mehrheiten im parlament suchen wollen
dann ist das zu akzeptieren wir stehen
bereit die zusammenarbeit fortzusetzen
kurz später bei zurück zu den grünen
doch ein weiter so ist dem
koalitionspartner nicht mehr zu
vermitteln
für sebastian kurz ist es jetzt
unfassbar eng geworden und de facto gibt
es für ihn kaum mehr möglichkeiten sich
da jetzt zumindest mittelfristig an der
macht zu halten die spitzen der vp
versammeln sich am abend zum
scherbengericht noch stehen sie hinter
ihrem kanzler doch kurz ist schwer
angezählt sein schicksal entscheiden
jetzt andere
klarheit wie es mit der regierung
weitergeht sollte das endgültig am
kommenden dienstag geben dann gibt es
eine sondersitzung im österreichischen
parlament
bei uns gibt es jetzt erst noch mal
nachrichten mit kasse die korona
pandemie hat deutliche löcher in die
staatlichen haushalte gerissen das
defizit im sogenannten gesamthaushalt
stieg im ersten halbjahr auf
131,1 milliarden euro im
vorjahreszeitraum hatte es noch bei 88
milliarden gelegen hauptgrund sind die
hohen ausgaben sie stiegen infolge der
korona pandemie um 10,8 prozent
zwar nahmen die haushalte auch mehr ein
das plus lag bei 6 prozent allerdings
können konnte dass die höheren ausgaben
nicht wettmachen
und während der staat ein dickes minus
verzeichnet haben die bürger unterm
strich deutlich mehr auf dem konto und
das nicht nur bei uns in deutschland
weltweit sind die vermögen auf einen
rekordwert gewachsen und der grund dafür
ist auch hier die korona pandemie wie
lautet die genaue erklärung stefanie
berit an der börse nun einerseits hat
die pandemie viel menschliches leid
verursacht und die wirtschaft
ausgebremst auf der anderen seite
erholten sich die aktienmärkte nach dem
kurzen schock wieder schnell weil
milliarden hilfspakete von staaten und
zentralbanken die krise abfederten so
wuchs laut einer studie der allianz das
weltweite geldvermögen der haushalte
2020 um fast zehn prozent auf die
rekordmarke von 200 millionen euro
verbraucher waren zum sparen gezwungen
weil konsum gelegenheiten fehlten
geschäfte und theater geschlossen
blieben und reisen nicht möglich waren
so legten haushalte mehr geld auf die
hohe kante wer das geld allerdings nur
beiseite legte musste zusehen wie die
inflation am ersparten knabbert
aktienbesitzer profitierten dagegen und
vermehrten ihr geld wie auch heute hier
wieder zu besichtigen tatsächlich legten
die deutschen im corona jahr ihren ruf
als aktien muffel ab und entdeckten die
börse für sich 12,3 millionen aktionäre
zählte das deutsche aktieninstitut
vergangenes jahr so viel wie seit 20
jahren nicht mehr experten beobachten
allerdings auch eine wachsende
vermögensungleichheit vor allem die
sogenannte mittelschicht wird kleiner
ihr anteil am gesamtvermögen nimmt
weltweit weiter ab stephanie vielen dank
frankfurt ein starkes erdbeben hat den
südwesten von pakistan erschüttert
mindestens 20 menschen kamen ums leben
außerdem gab es hunderte verletzte unter
den trümmern suchen helfer nach
verschütteten der erdstöße der stärke
5,9 hatten viele im schlaf überrascht
möglicherweise gab es auch opfer in
einer eingestürzten kohlemine
eine überraschung gab es heute in
stockholm der literaturnobelpreis geht
an einen schriftsteller der selbst
kennern der szene kaum bekannt ist
nämlich an abdul rasak ua aus tansania
und damit an den erster afrikaner seit
18 jahren
der 73-jährige schildere in seinen
werken kompromisslos und mitfühlen die
auswirkungen des kolonialismus das sagt
die schwedische akademie über gurtner
der in den 60er jahren als flüchtling
nach großbritannien kam auch den
deutschen buchhandel traf die
auszeichnung unerwartet keines seiner
übersetzten bücher ist derzeit lieferbar
das wird sich ändern und zwar in kürze
sowie zwei danken herzlich für ihr
interesse und morgen freuen sich hier
marietta slomka und hans wolf auf sie
ja und wir empfehlen ihnen jetzt noch
das heute-journal update mit christina
von ungern-sternberg um kurz nach halb
eins in allen einen angenehmen
ausschüssen
[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen zum wetter
schauen auf die temperaturabweichung
weltweit und da war der september in
diesem jahr mit den vier wärmsten
september zusammen also 2019 2020 und
das jahr 2016 diese vier jahre inklusive
2021 waren die wärmsten im datensatz des
kopernikus programms aber in europa war
es sehr unterschiedlich deutlich wärmer
nach westen hin und deutlich kühler nach
osten hin dass kommt zustande wenn
wettersysteme steckenbleiben apropos
stecken bleiben das passiert auch in
europa zurzeit im süden unter da hängt
ein tief und bringt grosse regenmengen
bis freitag bis zu 300 liter auf den
quadratmeter auf dem balkan ansonsten
haben wir es auch mit einem sehr
umfangreichen hoch zu tun im osten das
ist ja auch stecken geblieben seit über
einer woche schauen wir auf das wetter
und im osten deutschlands da bildet sich
nebel im süden gibt es etwas regen nach
westen hin lockert es auf und dort wird
es am kühlsten mit 3 grad in den
westdeutschen mittelgebirgen ganz im
osten ist es gerade mal zweistellig mit
zehn grad ja und morgen nach
nebelauflösung sonnenschein in der mitte
und nach süden viele wolken aber auch da
zeigt sich mal die sonne das bei
höchsten temperaturen von 19 grad im
rheinland und 12 grad in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen ja und am wochenende
bleibt es ruhig nach nebelauflösung viel
sonnenschein temperaturen am samstag 11
bis 19 grad und danach ein wenig kühler
ein schöner abend